cat out has concluded that their
packaging subscriber is going to receive
a large number of messages stay tuned to
find out when and how using pull
subscribers
[Music]
so far in the series we learned about
cloud pub/sub how it works
using cat outs asynchronous order
processing service we saw how pops-up
helps manage the interactions between
order packaging shipping and
notification services in the last
episode we learnt that pops-up supports
both push and pull message delivery
let's do a quick recap push delivery
requires the client to be a public HTTP
endpoint if you don't have one which
means your services private or firewalls
are involved then you would use pull
paul is also more efficient and
minimizes latency so if events are
generated at say hundred or thousand
requests per second then pool is your
friend so today let's focus on cat out
services to learn pull subscribers let's
say it is the high season for cat out
lots of people are ordering pretty cat
posters which means the packaging
service needs to process this huge
traffic with a efficiency and low
latency and we also know that the
packaging services internal and does not
have a public HTTP endpoint given these
conditions large requests per second low
latency requirements and no public HTTP
endpoint the best way to set up our
packaging subscriber is in pull mode the
pub/sub service offers two api's for
retrieving messages in poland there's a
pool api and there is a streaming pool
api the default is a streaming pool api
which is the most effective way to
achieve high-volume processing
asynchronously and for this reason
default client libraries just use
streaming pool for maximum throughput
and lowest latency streaming port is
actually a lot like push in that it
allows pops up to push messages to the
client as they become available the
difference here is that the client gets
to initiate this bi-directional
persistent connection the protocol here
is also a lot more efficient than HTTP
POST used by push
cat outs packaging service requires
high-volume processing and the best way
to achieve high-volume processing is by
processing asynchronously so a kacheng
service should just use default client
libraries that use streaming pool api
and offers maximum throughput and low
latency now that we know how a message
is received by full subscriber let's
double-click on the message itself the
message is sent by the publisher can
contain custom attributes and in
subscriber code you will have to process
those attributes in cat outs case Savior
sending the message from order service
to packaging subscriber there would be
custom message attributes to include
like user ID City and poster ID let's
see how to send and receive these
message attributes we all use the same
QuickStart code we used in episode 3 if
you've not seen it now is the time to
check it out and then continue on here
we are in our Python QuickStart folder
let's open pub dot P by in the pub
method we will add the logic to update
the message to include custom attributes
the user ID city and post rating then we
open two terminals to start our
packaging subscriber and one and send
the order message from the order
publisher in the other and we see that
the message with the same message ID is
received by the packaging subscriber
with the custom attributes that were
sent now
what if suddenly cat out becomes famous
and their order rate increases rapidly
since messages are being published at a
higher rate than they are being consumed
they will have to be processed fast
enough if this situation persists then
cat out should consider increasing the
number of subscriber client instances to
process the requests in parallel but if
this is a transient spike in messages
say to you to Black Friday or more cat
birthdays in a month then there could be
a few possibilities it's possible that
one client could have a backlog of
messages but another client in the
network has capacity but this free
client cannot process those messages
because the first client maintains the
lease
it's also possible that the client
libraries repeatedly extend the
acknowledgement deadline for backlogged
messages those messages continue to
consume memory CPU and bandwidth
resources and eventually the subscriber
runs out of those resources to mitigate
these issues you need to use the flow
control feature of the subscriber in
this Python example we are limiting the
subscriber to only have 10 outstanding
messages at a time in the high volume
context it is important to mention that
the subscriber also support concurrency
depending on the programming language
for language implementations that
support parallel threads such as Java
and go the client libraries make a
default choice for the number of threads
but this choice may not be optimal for
your application if you find that your
subscriber applications not keeping up
with the incoming message volume but is
not CPU bound you should increase the
thread count and for CPU intensive
message processing operations reducing
the number of threads might be
appropriate now there could be times
when you see duplicate messages from
pops up this usually happens when you
acknowledge a message before it's
acknowledgement deadline has expired so
pops up we sends the message leading to
duplicates you can detect this behavior
in stackdriver by monitoring the
acknowledged operations for the expired
response code to reduce the duplication
rate extend the message deadline some
client libraries handle this
automatically but if you are building
your own client library then use modify
act deadline method to extend the
acknowledgement deadline on the other
hand if you want to force pops up to
retry a message just set modify a
deadline to zero now there are cases
where you might need to do a bit more
work than just using the asynchronous
client library we've been talking about
so far in those cases you would use the
synchronous pull API it's recommended to
use synchronous pull when the
application logic might rely on a
polling pattern to retrieve messages or
your application
where's a precise cap on the number of
messages retrieved by it streaming pool
at the moment can over deliver before it
settles down so when you have a spiky
load of very small messages it can get
you in trouble those applications are
better off using synchronous form or in
the third case if you're using a
language framework like PHP for example
that does not support G RPC and require
HTTP REST API then you have no choice
but to use synchronous pause if we focus
our attention on our cut out application
due to some resource constraints the
notification service is designed so it
can receive a batch of messages in a
single HTTP request and the number of
messages cannot exceed say 10 based on
what we just learned cat out should use
synchronous pull API in this specific
scenario all right so today we learned
how to receive messages using pull
method we looked at message flow control
concurrency streaming pull API and
dealing with duplicate messages join us
next time as we take on the next topic
receiving messages using push until then
give us a like subscribe and let us know
what you want to learn about cloud
pub/sub
[Music]